you see the new york times call for a
reality zara a realities are yes
but that's already what they are isn't
it but but i'm sorry they said a task
force
so they'll be more like a ministry of
truth yeah they're talking about a
cross-agency of
experts coming together to tackle
disinformation
and quote domestic extremism this is
called the ministry of chance yeah
the realities are i mean but but this is
that's not even the bigger story here
the person who called for it the new
york times officially called for this
with their
article by kevin rose saying that this
is a good idea and that this is needed
where have we come where we have the new
york times of all publications the
publication that by the way
told the american people that there was
weapons of mass destruction in iraq they
were the first ones to sell that lie to
the american people
and now they're telling us we need a
ministry of truth we need a reality czar
we need to have control of information
that they're going to be working with
tech platforms on
along with the government making sure
that information
is of course held in the hands of the
very few
it's it's repundant to see this here's
my favorite part so wait we have the
article from the new york times
it says appoint a reality czar several
experts i spoke with recommend the biden
administration put together a
cross-agency task force to tackle
disinformation and domestic extremism
which would be led by something like a
reality czar
it sounds a little dystopian i'll grant
but let's hear them out sounds
it's like a guy coming and being like we
would like to have a camp
set up where you can take people who
believe bad things and are causing
problems
to place them for a certain period of
time and then maybe teach them things
to change the disinformation that way
they're no longer a threat to society
and i know i know it sounds dystopian
no i'm not going to hear you out we
don't want to read the ministry of truth
in this country yeah
i'm sorry the news publication that lied
to us and led to the deaths of hundreds
of thousands of people meaninglessly
that led to a migrant crisis
is not going to be lecturing me about
how truth needs to be controlled by
central forces in the government
what they're talking about here is
essentially the tech platforms
working with experts from agencies all
around
uh the united states government to fight
conspiracy theories they're the biggest
pushers of conspiracy they're 100
percent
and and and it's just a slap in the face
yeah yeah that's one out of uh thousands
and with the new york times it goes so
much further back we were talking about
this on the show i think the last time i
was here
and how the uh the holiday morning was
covered up by the new year oh yeah their
journey
won the pulitzer prize for covering
amazing um and so yeah the press has
always been horrible and yeah the idea
that they would talk about conspiracy
theories when they just spent the last
three years claiming without any
evidence that the president of the
united states was
a russian asset they're bringing it back
baby they're bringing it back are they
trying to make it
jimmy kimmel saying wall street vets
russia probably some russian bots
how this is that like don't they they
have to understand how ridiculous that
is
that they do and they're laughing at us
here's the thing
when you look at the the media channels
let me let me do this let me
do it i'm gonna do a segment throwback
do it i'm gonna show you this image
we're gonna drag the young turks yes
no tim i don't want to do that this is
michael tracy
he tweeted lol if you are really this
obsessed with my tweets
seek help and it is tyt live
aoc's horrifying details of capital riot
offend pathetic michael tracy
who cares about michael tracy and i mean
no disrespect
i i follow him i think he's a good
journalist but he's not he's
not like a politician who's doing it
he's a guy on twitter he's a journalist
this is this is ridiculous yep
and so the the point is you look at how
the media reacts to
to these stories that's what's
acceptable
that's the kind of news that they deem
crazy when there's a slow news day
don't try and make news just focus on
the federal reserve
break it apart i love it some tells me
they're not gonna do that anytime soon
but man do i wish i highly doubt that
well tucker carlson actually brought up
the federal reserve and the larger
economic impacts that they're having on
society which is really surprising
seeing
him say hey we should be focusing on the
fed which was
just quite mind-boggling when did he do
this yesterday oh good for him yeah
but again you know other individuals in
the mainline establishment media their
lies
they're harmful and they're they're
amplified and they're promoted with
rigged algorithms that of course have
their insider buddies promoting them so
you see them first
and you have no other option even if you
search for news and even independent
news
there was even a time where you typed in
and searched for my news organization
you couldn't find it
you would get articles with the
mainstream media bashing me
so so it's just absolutely ridiculous
but another layer here
we need to understand that's critically
important is that the big
tech social media companies the
technocrats are really the ones in
charge that are pushing a lot of this
nonsense that are controlling the
conversation
controlling the narratives and this is
why issues like alexandria ocasio-cortez
are being brought up
and then dunking and criticizing and
attacking individuals like jimmy dore
glenn greenwald michael tracy all of
them
is is in my opinion coordinated because
we have seen attacks on both
on three of these individuals in such a
way that that
really is perplexing because it
absolutely makes no sense
there's no rational sense to attack them
from a logical perspective what are they
going to do
you mean from an honest perspective yes
logically it makes tons of sense
michael tracy glenn greenwald jimmy dore
are all rather left-wing individuals
i would i don't necessarily think it's
fair to say michael tracy has left wings
i don't think he tweets about
supporting left-wing policy he's just
heterodox and glenn greenwald
actually is fairly progressive and jimmy
dore is definitely on the left
yeah when they challenge the machine in
the establishment it's very difficult
listen
when we saw donald trump as president
you had
one side hate donald trump and this is
the point i was going to bring up with
the young turks
think about the people who watch the
young turks and are sitting there going
like oh michael tracy like he's so dumb
like wow so stupid these people
are with all due respect not
what's the right word i want to say
without calling them a disparaging term
uh just
there there's there's different tiers no
no there's different tiers of
individuals there's those
that would prefer to listen to some like
hardcore boring
seven men from tajikistan were arrested
today and there's like very
straightforward news then you get people
who will watch this more conversational
but a little higher level and you get
people who are like i want to hear about
aoc yelling at michael tracy and so they
watch that kardashian
when you're trying to tell people about
what's going on and when you're trying
to convince people of policy
but you have half this country that just
mindlessly follows along these
ridiculous narratives
how do you convince them to make better
moves that will help themselves it's
very very difficult so what happens is
you get people who might begrudgingly
vote for trump why critical race theory
is bad for instance james lindsay is a
good example
he's a left-wing guy he challenges the
the system
he says i'm going to vote for trump
because you know trump's better for
these reasons joe biden is the
establishment
who's going to do everything that the
left hates and everything the right
hates combines can bring all together
you end up with this very difficult
scenario
but in in in the media it's really easy
to split
the left and the right you got people
who supported trump well tell everybody
orange man is bad
most these people who watch like the
young turks and just want to hear the
drama we'll believe it
what happens when you get wall street
when you get wall street bets oh boy
when you get game stop
well now all of all of a sudden these
people who have been told over and over
again by the likes of the young turk
that wall street bad
well you can't just change their mind
now and say wall street good
so so what do they do well they distract
they try and shift the focus away
they bring up aoc they want a reality
czar
to make sure that you're not thinking
about the wrong thing there was one
article in the nation
where they said that uh wall street bets
like trumpism and cubanon
you see what they try and do exactly
when when they can't give you a dividing
line on trump because half the country
hates trump
they try and shift the narrative and
give you tabloid drama well it's
hilarious though because i think a lot
of people on the left are willing to see
this with this situation now the media
might have screwed themselves here
at least to some extent because there
are a number of people on left and you
look at like reddit reddit as often
pretty left-leaning politically and so
when they see themselves being
associated with white supremacists
or with donald trump because they're
upsetting people on wall street they
they might start to think maybe these
terms don't actually mean anything
because this is also something that
the vast majority of people who have
heard
of are very much in favor of like most
people who have seen the wall street bet
story they think it's hilarious
uh and so when you start telling them
well actually the people who are
disrupting the stock market and raising
the the price of the stock for game stop
and hurting this hedge fund
are white supremacists it sort of opens
up their eyes and they think oh
maybe maybe conservatives are telling
the truth when they say that word is
just thrown around or that phrase is
just thrown around it doesn't mean
anything
well you start to notice that if they're
calling of people who are having fun
with wall street vets white supremacists
they might just be calling
anyone that means that maybe you should
rethink what you're
you've been thinking about conservatives
maybe that's not what they're saying
maybe they're not telling you the truth
100 and they've overplayed their hand
and this is what they did with the word
racist they almost never say racist
anymore they always say white
supremacists because after the 2016
election they realized that it was not
effective anymore
yeah and so trump won despite the fact
that he was called racist all the time
so they said let's switch
to a heavier term let's be even more
explicit let's call them white
supremacists and so they started doing
that
and now they're calling um redditors who
are buying stock white supremacists so
they've
ruined that first for themselves too i
don't know what the next one's going to
be we saw financial times
say that some of these people were all
right and then they had to retract that
and be
okay that's not true now now they're
just going for it now they're like okay
look we need to manipulate people and
the scary thing is
that's why i mentioned the young turks
that's why i mentioned the michael
tracy's story
there are people who will just literally
believe whatever the media puts out
that's it and they'll follow whatever
story the media tells them to follow
and then you have the grifter lefties on
youtube who'll be like slay queen
woo and it's like weren't you just mad
at wall street like without
without naming this particular
individual you have one guy who's like
antifa is good you know and they're
they're destroying small businesses and
whatever but it's because they're
fighting the machine
then 25 000 troops get to deploy get
deployed to dc
and they literally lock down the entire
city in a military occupation
and the same guy who was cheering for
goes this is a good thing i'm in favor
of the military lockdown i'm like dude
do you have any real opinions you're
just supporting whatever it is
the right doesn't like i think the
problem i have with this conversation
is that we're like okay this fire is
burning and destroying things
and see i'm scooping fuel into the fire
right now we're going to scoop some fuel
into this fire by talking about it no
you're wrong that's what we're doing
right now
we're spreading water you're saying look
having this conversation
is scooping fuel in just so you know
because we're becoming the media that's
talking about it you're wrong
we're spraying water on it right now i i
wholeheartedly disagree when we bring
this crap
up and go talk about this junk we're
propelling it but we're acknowledging
that that is what we're doing
so so when we're showing people this
this if you're if you're
if you're falling for this and you're
talking about it you're fueling it
so when we literally do a segment saying
don't fall for the tricks of the media
and the manipulation and focus on what
matters
we're making it worse like we're like
don't fall for this
and we're doing it what are we doing
we're fueling the fire what fire what
are you talking about the fire of
michael we're specifically [ __ ] crap
this is the media's manipulation
and we're focusing on the new york times
calling for abide in reality czar
to manipulate what you can know if we
don't talk about that and people don't
know they're doing it
then they'll get away with it we're not
talking about aoc that's why we're like
criticizing the young turks this is how
the fire is fueled that's what we're
doing right now and we're doing it and
we're showing them this is how it's done
this is the fire the the fire is when
you get left-wing channels like the
young turks
telling you not like creating content
that shifts your focus away from
high-level issues like media
manipulation
and hedge fund manipulation and tells
you to pay attention to some dude on
twitter
what we're doing is we're calling that
out a step back
and saying don't let the media
manipulate you so you you need to pay
attention to wall street and to pay
attention to the headphones
and don't let them divide us i'm not
going to sit here and rag on aoc because
she was scared
i respect her telling her story i
understand why she was scared
i think what i think what she does when
she promotes stuff is bad politically
because she's essentially just using
whether she knows it or not these pr
tactics to shift the narrative onto her
to build up more
you know press attention and things like
that and i fully recognize that we give
her attention we talk about it i'm not
super worried about that
my issue is they want us fighting they
want us
mad at aoc they want us yelling at her
no i would like her to actually tweet
more about wall street and hedge funds i
respected that i i praised that rashida
taleb as well
i don't want them to divide us and i
think it's important that we sit here
and say
look where the look what the new york
times is now saying biden should have a
reality czar a task force
to stop disinformation but we're calling
them out for being the liars it makes me
think
have you ever read 1984 it's a it's a
the orwell book
there's a point yeah the ministry of
truth is like this reality czar in the
book they have this hour of hate
where every day they have everybody sits
in front of the tv for an hour and just
thinks about hate and that's like what
this stuff is
they're you know they're just trying to
drive people i think it can be agree
i would disagree because i think that
what alexandria ocasio-cortez is doing
is very clever and very cynical and
something that no one has really touched
on is the fact that she's talking about
cops
she's rolling it into her own rhetoric
and she's talking about how the cop made
her feel unsafe
that's a very clever way of bringing
your ideas into the conversation
and bringing emotion in with it as well
you were terrified it was a cop you
didn't know if you were going to be like
poor george floyd or whoever has been
most recently assaulted by a policeman
you keep bringing up constantly i think
it's fair to
disagree with with with aoc but when i
like i mentioned earlier like she does
this instagram thing and i'm kind of
like
okay like that's fine i understand her
story okay
but what's happening now is rolling
stone newsweek young turks etc
are are putting this into everyone's
face that's fire
we are telling you don't get distracted
by the drama don't let the manipulation
and the low level
you know conversations dominate your
minds
so what we're doing now is we're
discussing the idea of media
manipulation
a ministry of truth realities are
because in my opinion
if they did have a reality czar first of
all that's psychotic it's insane
but it would essentially their goal
would be to make sure we don't talk
about these conversations we don't
we we just had luke calling out you know
the human right human rights abuses in
yemen
we're talking about voting for war and
and these and these emotionally
manipulative tactics they don't want us
talking about it
and i mean by like the new york times
the politicians they
want us distracted they want to take a
story aoc put out that has no bearing on
my life or anyone else's
and make it a major news story so we
stop talking about
hedge funds and wall street and the
short sellers
which we're talking about now that's the
point of this segment that's the point
of doing things like have you heard that
statement
uh that phrase by marshall mcluhan he
says the medium is the message
and in that sense if we choose to spend
two hours
talking about the problems in the media
we've actually become the problem in the
media how does that make sense because
we're stooping to that level we're
slinging
we're acknowledging the mud but in order
to do that we have to get in the mud
so it's good to talk about i pointed out
but to revel in it is
like if we spent we've already spent 40
minutes talking about it so we have two
different issues first we addressed the
tabloid drama nonsense
and how it distracted we shifted into
the new york times wanting to have a
reality
czar and what that means for the country
and so the way i see it is
look you've got a problem if you want to
put a fire out and save the people from
the fire you gotta run into a burning
building
so we could choose not to talk about any
of this and let it fester and grow and
get worse
or we can use our platform to challenge
it and say
this is this is bs and we have to call
it out to address it as a problem
and then quite literally what we're
doing is the solution
letting people see and hear our ideas
and if they agree with us then those
ideas
propagate you've changed my mind oh
there we go
nice awesome you know and i have to say
man i've never seen you that fired up
about anything on the podcast i actually
really appreciate it haven't you ever
seen the
arguments we've had it's good times no
no i guess not enough of them
they're out there he got fired up that
was i yeah i haven't seen that for me
medium manipulation it's a double-edged
sword i hear you yeah
it's look it's a double-edged sword
right so i i've done numerous videos
ragging on democrats
recognizing that it's it's it's
convenient for the establishment to have
the partisan divide
but how do you and this is why i love
the gamestop story
how are you supposed to point out that
it typically is
democrats causing the problems don't get
me don't get me wrong republicans
to a great degree causing problems
there's just slightly more republicans
than democrats who are doing better but
they're all
they're all just so awful right so when
you have
donald trump and his critics are so
insane that you're like this is not
legitimate criticism of a president
and you need to call it out i get emails
from people all the time saying how do i
convince
my family members that the media is
lying to them and i'm like
show them the truth and they're like
yeah but they don't believe it they
don't they they don't want to watch the
news they don't want when i send them a
link saying
here's the real video of donald trump
they say i'm not watching that
and now it's really really simple show
them reddit.com
and then google search reddit silver
and then what you see is on google all
of these news stories
you know dozens hundreds saying reddit
says buy silver
and then show them reddit.com do not buy
silver
it's there the veil has been shattered
now we're getting this tabloid drama
trying desperately to shift the
narrative away to something
unfalsifiable
this story about aoc and michael tracy
is a really good example it's
a of an excellent manipulation tactic
there's no right or wrong answer
it is a tribal agreement or disagreement
do you not like aoc do you like aoc
therefore there's no way to look at that
story and call it fake news
they've been able to now attempt this
media attack
to trick boomers for the most part into
buying silver when reddit was saying
don't do it
when people started to see how they were
lying and manipulating they said go for
an emotionally driven headline
that will dominate the press and
manipulate people into reading news that
can't be right or wrong
100 yeah and that's what's so insidious
it's it's the stories that aren't fake
like you said this is something that
actually happened as he's actually
talking about this but there is
something we're being distracted from
the easiest way the most important
takeaway from the whole thing
is this the story isn't true or false
and that's what's important for them get
everybody emotionally charged up
demanding their right but being but it's
impossible because it's an opinion
well i can tell you one thing that's
true or one thing it's false reddit did
not say by silver
and the media did lie when they claimed
reddit did
that is the red pill like that is a red
pill
that you can literally just hand to
somebody and there's it's like it's like
dissolves in their skin
they're gonna put in their mouth you
just show them these two things and
they're gonna be like that's
that's insane so immediately what
happens is they run full speed
and smack it out of your hand because
they don't want you to show people
what's actually going on
that's the point of these narratives
that's why the story was trending on
twitter
not and it's not necessarily because
like i think anyone conspired to make it
happen
what i think happens typically is you've
got pr people who look for opportunities
to shift the narrative
i don't think anybody had a meeting and
they're like hey uc can you do a video
and do this and then we're going to try
and
you know highlight some individual cr
what happened was she told the story
a bunch of special interests who want to
shift the narrative saw the opportunity
and use their pr tactics to do so
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you